this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by stamps.com
expressvpn hawthorne upstart and omax
health
more on that later let's get into the do
the honeydew
with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here
doing it from the night pants studios
i'm ryan sickler ryan sickler on all
social media ryan sickler.com make sure
you're signing up for that uh
email blast over there and uh make sure
you are signed up for the youtube
channel all right get over there
sign up for the youtube channel sign up
for the patreon the honeydew with you
all
if you or someone you know thinks you
have a story that needs to be heard
please submit at honeydewpodcast
gmail.com um we have talked to
um a lady with two [ __ ] we have
talked to
a guy whose dad came out when he was
almost 50. we've talked to someone
whose wife was addicted to online video
games and married the king from the game
we have talked to um god we talked oh we
talked to a guy who died twice
talked to a dude who died twice also
talked to a guy who woke up to a
stranger in his bed when he was seven
years old apparently was terrorizing the
neighborhood so
you all got some [ __ ] stories keep
submitting them we'll keep doing them
uh and thank you to everybody out there
in night pants nation
i'm telling you guys sold out the
[ __ ] actual manufacturer so thank you
very much
they're all back we got night shorts
hoodies mugs all that stuff
the website is the honeydewpodcast.com
that's where you'll get all merch social
media all that stuff also as i say all
the time i record here at santa monica
music center
if you want to take some online lessons
this is the spot
go to santa monica music dot com use the
code honeydew they will give you
uh free registration they'll waive that
fee and give you uh
what one free lesson when you sign up
for a package
all right now that that's all out of the
way
let's get down to business as i always
say we highlight the low lights here
these are the stories behind the
storytellers
and uh this week our storytelling i'm
very excited to have her here first time
on the honeydew ladies and gentlemen
please welcome
sarah weinshank y'all yay
thank you i'm excited to be here thank
you for having me you are
thank you for putting up with me i've
been bugging the [ __ ] out of you we made
it happen
we did make it happen it always takes a
long time i tell everybody like it's not
that easy to get schedules together
even during a pandemic even during a
pandemic you're a busy woman
yeah so thank you for making time for me
thank you for having me um before we get
into
anything please promote everything okay
i have a podcast called
shank that's s-h-e-n-k that's available
on all streaming platforms it's a great
show i did it it's a great show
i had a lot of fun so much fun um it's
also on youtube
under sarah weinchang check that out and
then i did a
comedy central cannabis smoking show
called shanks for smoking you can find
that on youtube as well
and uh yeah that's it follow me on
twitter
and instagram princess shank princess
like normal and then another s-h-e-n-k
got it princess shank on instagram and
twitter
i made that handle not realizing that it
was gonna stick with me
through my 30s
so now i'm a [ __ ] princess for the
rest of my life
you know what i mean it's like i'm just
owning it now
because i can't change the handle once
you you have
you feel like it's who you are well let
me make you feel better about that then
because i tell my daughter all the time
she'll be six in october she's
super into princesses and everybody
there's a there's a whole
uh group out there that's like you know
you shouldn't raise your daughter like
that don't be princess or whatever and
i'm just like look man
these chicks have been through some [ __ ]
like every one of them's lost
a close relative they're all going
they've got a power they don't [ __ ]
understand they got a lot of [ __ ] going
on
and they're getting abused they're
getting treated like [ __ ] so i was like
you know what
it's not yeah it's not you gotta [ __ ]
be down
and then come to the top it's all about
that that [ __ ] transition and that
rise
[ __ ]
yeah and half the people out there
judging would never go through what
moana did
[Laughter]
some of you all can't even swim moana's
a survivor
mm-hmm so good on you princess shank
thank you so much um so let's start with
where you're from
originally and then we're gonna get into
um
an interesting story you have yeah you
have a story
this is the other thing too because a
lot of people do a life story
um kyra sultanovich did one year of her
life during a crazy pregnancy so
i'm uh excited to hear what you have to
share that's crazy i'm excited
um so you asked me where i grew up yeah
where are you from i am from the san
fernando valley
818. yeah love it um
yeah so i grew up in la which was
valley just like anywhere where in the
valley did you grow up
yeah um so i guess i had like access to
la
when i was a teenager which i took
advantage of i was a little wild
but um overall i like growing up in l.a
for sure
i love the valley yeah i'm like a valley
girl through in the row
listen i love the va i lived in sherman
oaks for
i mean over 10 years i loved it out
there yeah i love it i like you know
that little stretch there too is a great
run from encino to sherman oaks to
studio city oh it's really nice it's a
nice area
yeah so um when did you get into comedy
then was it
ten years ago but were you always going
to shows were you around like what got
you into
that well like as a kid i always
performed like i was in
theater a lot acting classes a lot and i
just wanted to be a performer and
growing up in l.a
i remember telling my parents like i
want to be an actress
and they're like we're not raising a
child star
okay so they did they weren't they were
not um what do they do at all
my dad is a lawyer my mom does his
accounting
so they're like no
i wanted to go to yeah and they're like
we're not taking you to auditions you're
going to school
and i was like there's all these kids in
my class and they get to miss school to
go to auditions
i think i should be going to auditions
so that was a regular thing for kids in
your school because we didn't have any
if you were missing there was something
going on yeah like this this guy that i
had a crush on he was like
um a background actor i didn't realize
he was a background actor because he
said he was in the movie little rascals
and i was like
yeah i'm gonna go see this movie how old
are you at the time
third grade okay and um i had a crush on
him and he was in little rascals
and then i was like mom you have to take
me to see little rascals so she took me
to see little rascals and you could just
see like the side of his arm
that was it and i just still remember
everything that's tight though yeah
i was i saw you kidding me yes yeah like
i wish that was me
yeah um and so they were like
no we're not gonna do that we're not
gonna be like stage parents
they my mom took me one day to be an
extra in an olsen twin movie which was
like the highlight of my life
which movie uh i don't know which movie
it was
i don't remember were you in it in it or
did it get like your hands like
my exactly it was my acting
teacher at the time her like claim to
fame i think she might have been like a
hack who knows
she was like i coached the olsen twins
with acting and i was like that's gonna
be my acting teacher it was like in
sherman oaks or studio
city and um she was like we're filming
this big movie with the olsen twins and
if you take my class and you want to
come be
a background actor you can so i begged
my mom to take me because i was also
obsessed with the olsen twins
so obsessed with them and she was like
fine and she took me to do it
and the other parents were so crazy that
she was like we're never doing that
again
i'll bet she was like that i hope you
had fun because we're never
doing that again and i was like what do
you mean this is the best day of my
[ __ ] life
um and like i literally just remember
like the olsen twins
getting their hair brushed and like
freshly powdered
and me being like damn i wish that was
me like come
give me a touch up you know like i just
remember being like
what is this like i want to be involved
in whatever this process is like
whatever this creative process is where
you can just
like play like that's what i want to be
a part of and so then
in like high school and stuff i did like
so many improv classes
and like theater stuff and did you did
they
offer out here in california did they
offer that kind of class
in high school and employment but it was
taught at your high school it was like a
theater slash
and it was like so fun and i love that
that seems very la or new york
or chicago yeah totally um
so i did that in high school and it just
like came very were you a good student
um
even though you didn't really want to do
that were you did you get a good grade
school i
had okay grades in college i got really
good grades okay
yeah where'd you go to college chapman
in orange county okay
very boring it's the most boring school
of all time
it was like literally like so many
boring like
rich white people i was like orange
county is not for me
it's not like the valley no there's no
diversity at all
everyone was like like the school that i
went to
this there would be kids who went to the
school and they were so stupid that the
only way
that they get into college was if their
parents
donated something to the school
so like this girl the dumbest girl
you've ever met in your life
right full plastic surgery she was only
in the school because
her parents donated a wing
to the school oh that kind of donation
i'm thinking like we got a buick out
back
yeah no no yeah a wedge
it's like it's like her last name was
the name of the wings
[Laughter]
it was crazy yeah you could skate by
when you got some [ __ ] like that yeah
i'm going to rehab for a little while be
back and she comes back and she's like
clean and like and then she's like go
away again get a
plastic surgery come back so like the
college i went to was very bizarre
and i hated it i was like i just want to
my parents were like
i didn't want to go to college i just
wanted to do acting my parents were like
no you're going to college and i was
like no i want to audition for the real
world
audition audition we're holding an
open casting in santa barbara i want to
audition for that
trust me this is the path that i'm on
and if i get onto the real world then
i'm not going to college and they're
like you're not doing that you're going
to college and i was like okay fine but
after i got out of college
i'm going to be in the real world and
they're like it'll still be hot it'll
still be
like okay whatever so i went to college
and i was like so
over it that i made i forced myself to
graduate early
because i just wanted to get out you
just took like a bow load of [ __ ] yeah
got it done
yeah did you commute or did you live i
lived in orange county
and i came home all the time i'd be like
[ __ ] orange county yeah so i'm gonna go
out in
l.a and then i before i did stand up i
would go out a lot in l.a
like what was going on for you before
stand up okay clubs
like um okay i had like a club phase
like an la girl um and it was
like from the time i was like 18 to 22.
okay and it was like i had a fake id
before i turned 21 and i would go to all
these clubs
and i would go like monday i go here
tuesday i go here
thursday i go here and it was like you
know everybody
and it's just like this empty scene of
like
club la kids and like i would go
hang out there and it would be like um
like this is cool nicole richie just
stopped by
paris hilton lindsay lohan like you're
seeing all that
seeing all of that and that was like
before like social media was
what it is now so it was like a big deal
and it was like oh my god a celebrity it
was like [ __ ] thing and i got
really like um sucked into that scene
before i started stand up
and then i found stand up and then that
basically saved me and what got you
stand up i took an acting class i was
taking an acting class and my acting
teacher was like you're really funny
um he gave everybody different
assignments he was like you have to
everyone was supposed to write a
monologue and for me he was like you're
going to write a stand-up set
oh nice and so my first stand-up set
that i ever did was actually in an
acting class so you never thought of
being a comedian or anything prior to
that or did you have
interest or did you you know did you
like comedy i loved comedy did you go
see
shows especially being out here not
really no i just like
for me like uh one of my earliest like
childhood memories was like my dad
watching robin williams and
his reaction to it was like i've never
seen him laugh
like that before so i think there is
like something
like like i just remember being like
that's a job i could do that
like let's do that like how do i do that
you know what i mean
so it was always like there but i didn't
really know
i thought i was going to be an actress i
didn't know i was going to get into
stand up and then i still
i did stand up in my acting class and
then i kind of just like didn't do it
for a little bit after that because like
what's the next step if you're new
and then i started my first show i ever
did was a bringer show at the comedy
store
wow nice very nice and bombed in front
of all of my uh family and friends
several times this is this is what every
comedian i talk to it's so funny
it makes sense why we're so broken and
why relationships
like we the the first overwhelmingly the
first experience was
miserable and we're still like i'm gonna
do this yeah i'm gonna torture myself
[Laughter]
like this sucked the first time man i
should do this oh my god
it's so bad like the stuff that i would
do when i first started i can't even
think about without feeling
well you have performed in some
interesting places um so how about
do you mind telling the story which
leads up to
apparently your performance as well yes
are you cool telling them the psych ward
story yeah
yes okay yes so let's back up for a
second
so like in high school my grades were
like what
they weren't that great and so and i
always felt like
not dumb but like i didn't understand
math or i didn't understand certain
subjects
like i didn't have an interest in them
so um
my comprehension like the way that i i
couldn't
process it the same way but like english
no problem
[ __ ] anything that was like writing
based or reading based
or like memorization based no problem
can i say this
i was in i'm not saying this to sound
like a douche but i was in like
accelerated classes
but math was i mean that was my
i would struggle to get a 70. yeah no
and i would use the gym
a to cancel out that c so i could get a
3.0 yeah that way i could get my
insurance cheaper and i could get that
free pizza hut pizza and [ __ ]
yeah but um but i always argued like
why does it have to be if you're in one
of the the gifted and talented classes
you gotta be in all of them like it was
like it's all or none i was like that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm i can't
i did intro to calculus i i audited they
wouldn't let me i wrote a fake letter
saying it was from my mom
and that i was academically misplaced
when i was a senior and they made me sit
in the calculus class but i was on
audit no yeah that's crazy
yeah so um so okay that's just kind of
like the backstory so then when i got to
college
a lot of people were taking adderall in
college
to like crank out the papers and like
get the [ __ ]
so from what i know meth is very popular
for
focusing and and running those long
nights but adderall
snorted right people snorting it we
would just take like take it
yeah it wasn't like we're snorting and
is it a speed thing
it is but like i also like as a kid i
definitely think that i had add
like i had a trouble like sitting down
and like focusing and doing [ __ ] because
i had like so many different ideas i
think that kind of just comes with like
the territory of like being a creative
person sure
and not everybody learns the same way
and at all
you know so there's so for me it was
like so then i started taking adderall
and in college
my grades were like incredible so did
you immediately notice a difference on
adderall like whoa
this is yes this product
productivity-wise yeah
okay like i could just like but not your
focus necessarily didn't change
all of it i could do anything
and it felt like i was like a genius and
it was all so easy for me
on adderall and so then after college
and like
i think that like our society rewards
people
for product productivity like everything
so action based like what are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
and um so after college i
uh before i well okay i started stand up
and then um i started staying up and
then i also had a personal assistant job
during the day
okay so i would do the personal
assistant job during the day and then i
would do stand up at night
so my day would start at like 8 30 in
the morning and then i wouldn't end
like two in the morning yeah so
i went to a psychiatrist and they
prescribed me adderall
so then i started taking adderall
throughout like that whole time and i
was like able to get everything i needed
to do
done and i felt like i was killing the
game
then but like also i was just on math
basically prescribed i'm like i'm
killing the game i'm the total [ __ ] to
be around because i'm coming down for
meth right now
um but like i am killing the game my
closet's never been [ __ ] cleaner
everything's color-coded i know where
everything is
like i felt like untouchable but
you know it's bad for you while you're
taking it because it's like
you're not sleeping you're not you don't
you not as much no you're not getting
proper sleep you're just not operating
like a
fully functioning person in the same way
you know what i mean
but you can do a lot um so what happened
was i decided that i wanted to get off
of it
because i was like this is not it just
felt like i wasn't
being authentic to myself and it
honestly started to feel like it was
like stifling my creativity
because it was like after how long after
like
months a year how long like five years
years okay
five years five years it was a long time
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor hawthorne so
i've told you about hawthorne already a
few weeks ago
and i'm telling you as far as the men's
products go
they're the best my stepson he took him
he started taking my cologne the
deodorant the shampoo everything like
i'm trying to have to split it with the
kid now and then we started talking
about it i was like you know what you
should you're 16 you
you got funk you should be wearing this
but so should i
and it's a good balance if you're
looking for like
something especially if you're a parent
looking for something for your teenage
boy or your husband or your boyfriend
it's
you want to try to get them into
different products this i'm telling you
this is the way to go all right they
have a quiz you can go right online take
a quiz
they ask great questions and they'll
tailor everything
right to you all right so uh the
deodorant the shampoo the body wash the
face cleanser all of it is great you
this is what you're gonna do you're
gonna take a quick two minute quiz
and hawthorne's going to tell you the
two clones that are best for you there's
one for work and there's one for play
it's totally risk-free with free
shipping and free returns
free free free so check out hawthorne.co
and i am saying that correctly it's
h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e
dot c-o and use the promo code honeydew
you'll get 10
off your first purchase that's
hawthorne.co
use my code honeydew to get 10 off your
purchase
our next sponsor is expressvpn all right
now we all know
expressvpn protects your privacy and
security online right but here's
something you might not
know you can also use expressvpn to
unlock movies and shows that are only
available in other countries
now now that so many of us are stuck at
home it's only a matter of time until
you run out of stuff to watch on netflix
so this whole week
i've been using expressvpn to binge
doctor who
on uk netflix it's so simple to do i
just fire up the expressvpn app
i change my location to the uk i refresh
netflix and that's it
alright expressvpn hide your ip address
and lets you control where you want
sites to think you're located so you can
choose
from almost 100 different countries so
think about all the netflix libraries
you can go through all right but it's
not just netflix expressvpn works with
any streaming service
that's hulu the bbc iplayer youtube you
name it there are literally hundreds of
vpns out there but expressvpn
is the way to go expressvpn is also
compatible with
all your devices your phones your media
consoles your smart tvs and more so you
can watch
what you want on a personal device on
the big screen wherever you are
so i want you to go visit my special
link right now at expressvpn.com
honeydew and you're going to get an
extra three months of expressvpn for
free
okay you can support the show you can
watch what you want and you can protect
yourself
with expressvpn at e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash honeydew our next sponsor
is stamps.com now as we slowly adjust to
a new normal we still need to be smart
about how we do business now luckily
there's stamps.com to make things
easier thousands of small business
owners have discovered the benefits of
stamps.com in recent months they've been
able to keep their businesses running
and avoid the crowds at the post office
all from their own computers with
stamps.com
you can print postage on demand and
avoid going to the post office and
you'll save money
with discounted rates you can't even get
at the post office stamps.com
also offers ups services shout out to
ups
baltimore hub primary one joe avenue
with discounts up to 62 percent
and no residential surcharges stamps.com
brings all the mailing and shipping
services you need right to your computer
in the comfort of your home or office so
whether you're a small business sending
invoices
if you're an online seller shipping out
products or you're just working from
home and need to mail stuff stamps.com
can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24
7 for any letter any package any class
of mail
anywhere you want to send once your mail
is ready you just leave it for your mail
carrier you schedule a pickup or you
drop it in a mailbox it's that
simple and like i said with stamps.com
you get real discounts too okay
five cents off every stamp and up to 62
percent off usps and ups shipping rates
stamps.com is a no-brainer saving you
time and money and right now
my listeners get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial
okay plus free postage and
a digital scale without any long-term
commitment
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in honeydew
that's stamps.com enter honeydew
now let's get back to the do um
and during that you were like i got this
[ __ ] i got this [ __ ] like during it it
was like
it was all very manageable like i
thought it was manageable but like
internally i knew i didn't want to be on
this
i didn't want to be like needing to take
a pill every day to like
do what i had to do um
but i also just felt like i was killing
it so why would i get off of it
um so i talked to my psychiatrist and i
was like i really want to get off
adderall and he was like okay we'll just
start like weaning down
and they're like i'm like okay can you
like tell me how to do that
so like just take less of it so i just
started taking less a bit like half
pills
half pills and i and it was like
i felt so tired all the time when i like
decreased the dosage instantly
like so tired but like not just like so
tired it feels like you're like coming
down from like
drugs and like you don't feel good it's
just like
bad um and then the
what happened was brody died and i was
like
i'm not going to take my medication
anymore because i just want to sleep
and so i just completely like i was so
depressed i just cut it
cold turkey and i went into like a crazy
like psychosis
for real so it was like right around
that time because i was like
i just want to be asleep like i'm so sad
about this like and then i just stopped
taking my medication
and like within like 72 hours i went
into like a psychosis
what are you starting to notice first
like what's the first thing you're
starting to feel
i didn't notice it my roommate at the
time was like [ __ ] you're crazy
really yeah you had no idea i
like i was just like there was so much
happening
because brodie had just died so i was
like so like
that was like so sad to me that like and
i
just stopped taking my medication
completely and that affects like
your brain chemicals and your serotonin
levels and there's like a way to taper
off of it
that a doctor is supposed to guide right
through the past and all the way out
until it's done
yeah and i just did it myself
and my roommate was like called my
parents and was like sarah's like
not doing well my parents were like what
are you doing that she's seeing that
i'm doing i'm waking her up at eight in
the morning i'm like hey what's up
she's like get out of my room what are
you doing and i was like
uh can i tell you something can i do
this like uh do you want to go to
breakfast she's like
no just like completely off the rails
and just like um like
like putting things together that didn't
really make sense and like
saying things that didn't really make
sense like i'm trying to think of like
i mean like i was definitely in a
psychosis because my parents were like
are you on drugs and i was like i'm not
currently on drugs but i have done a lot
of drugs
that was your answer yeah they're like
which drugs i'm like telling my mom
about
my mushroom trips and like my acid trips
and like
all this [ __ ] and i was like it was very
beautiful healing experience which is
like
obviously i wasn't operating as my
normal self because i was just like
divulging all this stuff to her
um but yeah just like all over the place
completely all over the place i can't
remember like the details because like
it almost feels like i like blacked out
okay but i remember like some highlights
of the whole experience
so um yeah so basically
my parents were like there's something
wrong with you
because i was acting really abnormal to
the point where like we have to call the
police
the police the police yes because that's
what um
to get me into the psych ward because
they didn't know what was going on
because they didn't
realize that i was on adderall they
didn't know
okay so i was like i took i took
adderall but i'm off of it now and
they're like
okay basically they thought that like
maybe i was like losing it
or like a full drug addict they had no
clue what was going on
i didn't really know what was going on
so then like 12 cops come to my parents
house
are you for real for real what time of
day is this
i mean it's like 6 30 p.m and they come
and i know and i charm we couldn't get
that from [ __ ] riots out here sarah i
charged them
i chopped them out of taking me to
cyborg how did you do it i was like i'm
fine like
yeah i was like very cooperative like
whatever they wanted i did and then they
left
and then i like went off the rails later
that night like was having a full mental
breakdown like
crying hysterically and like just like a
mess just like the combination of like
the brody stuff mixed with
getting off of this like yeah getting
off of prescribed meth like
pushed me over the edge um and so
basically like
then i had to ride in an ambulance to a
psych ward
they did check you in they checked so
they pick you up at your house they're
picking me up from my house and i
remember
all the neighbors outside and [ __ ] is
everybody watching actually don't know
but it was a spectacle for sure i'm sure
remember getting into this so wait i'm
sorry 12 cop cars show up
they leave cops they leave ambulance
shows up
next ambulance i mean there's a
situation over at the wine shank
yeah yeah yeah everyone on the street's
like oh this [ __ ] is what's going on
[Music]
it's all up here yeah
so i get into the i remember the
ambulance pulls up and i am like on
another level i'm like
oh my chariot has arrived did you say
that or you think that
i was like my chariot has arrived i'm
skipping into the ambulance like all
[ __ ] happy
like totally do you remember you
remember that never be like oh my
chariot has arrived and i remember
sitting in the ambulance and there was
like this hot black guy
in the ambulance with me and his last
name was johnson
and i yell out of nowhere big johnson
energy
i was like and then i start laughing
hysterically and like think i'm crushing
it with like
people like pounding them like yeah
what's up what's up i'm like friends
with all these people
this is crazy they get to the hospital
oh god i can't just feel that they take
me to the hospital before they take me
to the psych ward
i don't know why what hospital encino
hospital okay
made a big appearance at encino hall did
you kill there i can't enough
i made a scene there i was like
listening to like i remember just like
listening to music
and being like um this song is perfect
for right now in this moment it's like
you're in the hospital having like a
mental breakdown
i don't know it was just crazy but
basically um then they gave me like a
tranquilizer
so that they could take me to the psych
ward and figure out what was going on
with me because i was not making sense
so i just wake up in the psych ward and
i'm like where the hell
am i okay wait what is that like you
wake up and what is the room is it
okay the room is you have two roommates
they're in there with you you wake up
the strangers in there yes whoa that's
creepy that's [ __ ] weird
i've never woke up with people in my
room you wake up but you don't know
check out the honeydew with you all some
guy did though that yeah yeah
so [ __ ] crazy so i wake up and i
don't remember really anything because
they like tranquilize me to get
me in there and my roommate and the
psycho or two roommates goes
are you okay and when your roommate in
the psych ward
is you of you you're okay and i'm like
yeah i'm totally
fine like what and she's like you were
like screaming last night you were
making a huge scene i was like i was
and she's like yeah i'm like i have no
recollection of that at all and everyone
was like
are you okay i'm like i'm great are you
guys okay
what are you all doing yeah um i was
like
the crazy person at the psych ward
because i was like
coming down from adderall and like
hadn't slept in like a week
holy [ __ ] like the combination of like
sleep deprivation mix with like
grief mixed with like not getting the
proper like
brain chemicals that you're supposed to
get just like
push me over the edge and put me in like
a psychosis so i had to stay
at the psych ward for three days and
being at the psych ward is the craziest
[ __ ] ever tell me the ru describe the
room that you're in
that you stay in mostly okay well
there's your bedroom area
and you go there at night oh that's
pretty much it but it's like
very clean the place that i went to was
actually like a nice one
i can't a nice one yeah which i can't
imagine what a not nice one would you
like um but the room they like clean it
a lot and there's like three beds
lined up they're no bunk beds no just
three lined up and then you have a
bathroom that you share with your three
three roommates and is it in an open
floor plan or is it a
door shut it's like no privacy there's
doors but they take
you they take your phone they take all
your personal belongings when you arrive
they shoelace shoelaces
and i remember looking down at my shoes
you remember what you were wearing
yeah yeah oh what i was wearing was
insane
yeah okay i had this pajama shirt that
was it was like for some reason i was
like this is what i'm gonna wear and it
was like because i love clothes but like
the outfit was insane i had on a um
it was like a toy soldier
like pajama christmas shirt
so from the top it looked like i was a
toy soldier
oh actually i get it yes yeah not toy
soldiers all over but like the owl it
was like the outfit like
gold like things like this and like i
was just like a toy chariot
you got to get this like i was like like
bring bringing some heavy princess
energy
to the [ __ ] psych ward and then like
mismatch
socks like if you saw my outfit you'd be
like yeah she belongs in the psych ward
which is unusual for me because i always
wear i'm always like on point with you
yeah
i was you took the words out of my mouth
i even
message you you are on point you are all
i can't imagine what you'd be going in
yeah
so i had a toy soldier shirt on top and
then i had
101 dalmatian shoes and they were
and they took the shoelaces out of them
because the headspace i was in was like
oh yeah 101 domination shoes [ __ ] yeah
like i feel like i really regressed
during my psychosis like i became very
child-like okay
and um i had these like uh
101 dalmatian shoes on and they didn't
have any like
[ __ ] shoelaces and i remember looking
down at my shoes and being like this is
some mentally
ill [ __ ] like to be wearing a hundred
and one dalmatian shoes and you don't
even have the laces so that you don't
kill yourself like that's
insane it's the bomb i had to throw out
the 101 dalmatian juice i'm like
uh it's time to let these go
i love that that's what it took for you
to find out woman
[ __ ] throw out the 101 nomination shoes
what are you doing like pull it together
um so i remember just like
looking down at my shoes and being like
ugh i can't believe i don't have
shoelaces
so insulting so gross like i just
um okay i'm trying to think what else
happened so
basically they give you medication while
you're there whatever you meet with a
doctor in the psych ward and they just
like medicate you to keep you like
in check and you have to take whatever
they give you you don't even know really
what they're giving you really
yeah they're like here's your medication
and you haven't been able to tell anyone
look i'm i took
adderall you haven't been able to tell
anyone that you're the doctor and they
tell you
and like i'm like i took adderall i
stopped taking it and they did this and
they just like
i think they give you like um anxiety
medication basically
like my parents just didn't know what
was going on with me and they thought
that i was like a harm to myself
so they're like we just want to make
sure and were you were you aggressive at
all or physical with anyone else
i was just like
very like traumatized by what it just
happened and like very sad
and then also i hadn't slept and also
just like my brain chemicals were off
like i definitely needed
help for sure um so like in hindsight
it's pretty much like the best thing
that's ever happened to me because
i'm off adderall but um it was a [ __ ]
journey
i mean i remember like it was easier to
get like an anxiety medication than it
was to get chapstick or like a cough
drop
i was like can i get a cough drop and
they're like
because i was yelling so much i remember
yelling so much
and there my voice was like all like
scratchy and i was like can i get a
cough drop
like we you actually had a cough drop 30
minutes ago so
technically we have to wait another hour
really
i was like for a [ __ ] cocktail weird
rules i'm like who eats cough drops as
prescribed
like you follow the exact rules on the
cough drop bag i
could like i didn't even know they had
finished a cough drop bag in like an
hour
yeah you know yeah that's how i feel
it's the candy what do you mean i just
want something to suck on while i'm in
the psych ward
um do i come back not yet i was like
okay um
and i just remember but here's some
lithium yeah
the other people that were walking
around were [ __ ] insane too
i remember what yeah what do you
remember okay so this girl who had like
this shaved head she was like
she became my friend she kept asking me
these questions and i was like
she's like i need a lawyer and i was
like i need a lawyer too
and my dad's lawyer so i call my dad i'm
like hey dad i need a lawyer
and he's like for what and i was like to
get me out of the psych ward he's like
you're not coming out of there you have
to say that for three days that's part
of it and i was like
oh so you can't be my lawyer to get me
out of here he's like no i put you in
there
oh your lawyer put you in
oh my oh [ __ ] damn good point
maybe you'll have better luck yeah
i just remember there was this guy so
they have like this pay phone which it's
like
why do they have a pay phone it's like a
pay phone like an old school paper yeah
it's like in the middle of the hall
and it has a very short cord because
they don't want you to hang yourself
is that right yeah it's like the
shortest cord you could ever imagine
so you're like you have to talk like
this it's like
it's literally it's in the middle of the
hall
so it's like if you make a phone call
then everyone like can see
what's going on so like there's this guy
that came out and i just remember
he had no pants on he just had on like
like a
like a night like some type of like
night pants night game
that was short and then his like he had
on like brief underwear and i could see
his balls and his butt
and he was like on the phone like
calling his wife and i was just like
i got someone in the psych where i was
like can you ask this guy to put on some
pants because i keep looking at his
balls and they're like
they're like short princess wants you to
put them on the plane
then there's like okay so then there's
like an entertainment room
that's where you hang out okay in the
energy what sort of games are you
allowed to play if you can kill yourself
all the cookies are in there playing
games so it's like
taboo okay which that goes hard for
yourself
you can't kill yourself i mean you could
probably beat somebody like the buzz or
the devs
categories they have magazines in there
they have tv
they have coloring books they have and
if you're
and as because i was like regressing so
i was like
coloring non-stop how was your
yeah i was killing the coloring game um
and then okay the the food in the psych
ward we have to talk about the food
okay so the food in the psych ward
shockingly good
really i mean the chicken feta
first of all i have something called
chicken feta
feta chicken i don't know what it is i
don't know if that's just something they
make there
but i was like this is incredible this
is literally
the best like i give the psych ward one
star but i give the fed a chicken [ __ ] i
give this like word chef
yeah but the funniest was one night
they i go what's for dinner they go a
mcrib
excuse me you're giving me a mcrib
you guys are ripping off mcdonald's
mcrib in the psych board and that's why
you're feeding me
loved it by the way was it a real mcrib
oh it was their version
of that the mac rib
it was like that was like to me the
funniest you loved it
i thought it was the funniest thing of
all time
like what alternate universe am i in
where like they're giving me a mcrib
and it's good and like the fed of
chickens incredible
and then so like in the entertainment
room i start talking to like the other
inmates or whatever the other hostages
and they're like i'm like i do stand up
and they're like really i'm like yeah
you guys want to show
they're like yeah i'm like cool okay so
i start doing stand up for like
yeah stand up at the psyche
i was like why not i have a live
audience did you remember your setting
that was clear i got
so there's like uh there is a pepper
shaker
on the um in the like you got balls girl
you have a ball
shaker by like in the same in that uh
in the area where everyone was hanging
out and it was the only thing that kind
of
looked like a mic so i started using it
as my mic because like you didn't even
have a real microphone
i started doing with the pepper shaker
how many people were there probably like
seven
that's what it's like now and look
the guy the cyborg guy comes in or
whoever's in charge like you can't do
you can't use the they gave you the
light he lit me for using the pepper
shaker as a mic
and i go come on i go why can't i use
the pepper shaker as a mic it's this
it's fine if i sprinkle it on food but
if i use it like this that's a problem
like i didn't understand i was so
appalled so then i couldn't use the
pepper they took away the pepper shaker
so i'd use my fist and pretend like i
had a mic
yeah then i started networking with the
people at the psych ward i'm giving away
my twitter handle
which i don't really remember probably
because i was like on anti-anxiety meds
so i'm like they don't want to open for
you i go hey follow me on twitter
i tweet and so i get back tweet i get
back from
the psych ward and i tweet um
like hey
something about how i was the most
popular girl in the psych ward like as a
joke i thought it was funny to myself
i thought i was killing it this chick
who started following me from the psych
ward
responds and goes actually to be honest
i think dara was more
and i was like what the hell
hold on yeah yeah
oh my god so wait all right
you're in there you did a lot in three
[ __ ] days by the way good for you
that's that awesome
yeah did you sleep comfortably there i'm
curious did you were you
able to you like it was the first time i
actually was able to sleep in like a
long time because they give you like
medication that helps you sleep they're
knocking you out they're basically like
drugging you into like
submission and you're like okay and then
after i got out of the psych ward i got
a psychiatrist
and then from there i've been fine so
like it's all been fine since then
so what what happens when you get out
like
well when you get out you feel like an
actual crazy person because
you're like wait i was actually in a
psych ward because if you would have
told me that i was going to end up in a
psych ward
ever in my life i would be like you're
insane that's never going to happen to
me
so afterward it's like this like trauma
of being like
held somewhere against your will
basically for three days and like
realizing like the repercussions of
taking prescribed meth for five years
yeah you're right though yeah and so
you're like oh it wasn't just like uh
there's like no easy pill to like get
exactly what you want
no you know what i mean there never is
never um
so yeah so afterward i had to be in like
therapy
and try to figure out you know
uh whether or not i needed to be
medicated for add
and i don't need to be because it's like
when i
when i was taking adderall i was like i
was a personal assistant doing like data
entry
it's a lot different than being a
standout yeah
or being a podcaster or you know what i
mean so
luckily i've been able to like be fine
and like my life has become
exponentially better from
getting off of adderall and it's just
scary that so many people are prescribed
it
especially children yeah i didn't even
know that and
this is all news to me didn't know
anything like that could happen it's
really bad for your
nervous system prior to this did you
know that could happen or have you ever
met anyone since that this happened to
no no no um but my psychiatrist thought
it was like a combination of like
the grief mixed with like the cold
turkey not taking
the medication yeah he's like that's why
you can't just not
take something you've been taking for
five years and just
yeah yeah so what was therapy like i
mean are they trying to dive deep on you
to see if there's real [ __ ] going on or
are they
sort of yeah what was up yeah no i went
to like a lot of therapy i went to
first it was like twice a week did you
ever go before this incident
yeah i had therapy before but um
this therapist was like the therapist
that i went to was like a genius and
like really understood
like the brain and like neurology and
just everything and he was just
amazing and basically like saved my life
great yeah
yeah so for a while it was therapy twice
a week
now i go once a month and yeah
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our next sponsor upstart during
these economically turbulent times
everyone is looking for a way to feel
more financially secure so if you're
still needlessly throwing money every
month at high interest credit card debt
it's time you checked out upstart the
revolutionary online lending platform
that knows you're more than just a
credit score
now is the time to find out how low your
upstart rate can be to help pay off
high interest credit card debt unlike
other lenders upstart can reward you
based on your education and job history
in the form of a smarter rate
you don't need a degree or a diploma to
apply though upstart lets you skip going
to the bank because it's completely
online
they offer loans from a thousand to
fifty thousand dollars so you can
consolidate your debt into one easy
fixed rate payment
upstart makes it fast and simple to
check your rate
and since it's just a soft pull it does
not affect your credit score
the hard pool happens if you accept your
rate and you proceed with your
application and the best part
is if the loan is approved and accepted
most people get their funds the very
next business day
over 400 000 people have used upstart to
pay off credit cards or meet their
financial goals
free yourself from the burden of high
interest credit card debt
and get back to using your money your
way with upstart
see why upstart has a 4.9 out of 5
rating on trustpilot and
hurry2upstart.com
honeydew to find out how low your
upstart rate can be
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes that's upstart.com
honeydew our next sponsor is omax
cryofreeze
living with chronic pain is the worst
it's more than a feeling of discomfort
it can affect your whole life i know
many of you have probably
some kind of pain that you deal with
it's prevented you from relaxing and
sleeping or
stopped you from exercising perhaps it's
been ongoing for a few weeks now
and hasn't improved with any of the
treatments you've tried enter
omax health if you're looking to get rid
of nagging muscle and joint pain
immediately while providing long-lasting
recovery
then you need to try the natural
breakthrough pain relief solution
cryo-free cbd roll-on developed by omax
health
this is a non-prescription triple action
pain relief roll-on it's specially
formulated to block pain receptors
reduce inflammation and improve muscle
and joint flexibility
the best part is this 100 natural cbd
powered remedy works its magic within 10
minutes of application
and relief lasts up to 8 hours much
longer
than the over-the-counter products i
told you since god it's been december my
neck's been killing me my shoulders my
trap my neck and i just been using that
roll on and it works
it really works it makes everything
tolerable
so much better and quick all right so
here's the deal that they're offering
omax health
is offering you guys 20 off a full body
cryo-free
cbd pain relief roll-on plus free
shipping
this discount also applies toward any
product site-wide okay so just go to
omaxhealth.com today
enter code honeydew that's omax
health.com and enter code honeydew to
get 20
off cryofreeze and sitewide now
let's get back into the do do you talk
about this in stand-up as well
no well okay this is the thing um a lot
of my stand-up is
like dry observational stand-up
and i was trying to incorporate the
psych ward material
into um my stand-up
and then the pandemic happened so like
my goal is to incorporate it into my
stand-up
when stand-up comes back because like
there's something about the mcrib and
like it lives at the psych war the rest
of the year when it's not at mcdonald's
there's i like that there's also
something about it
you guys i love food you know where the
best chicken food i've ever had in my
life is
just like like wait what should i just
walk
it's so crazy because i had like so much
shame associated with it and it was such
like a moment that like
i felt like defined me and i was like
shame in what way like of like
i'm a crazy i went to the loony bin
that's like a thing that doesn't
really happen for three days yeah but
like it's just like
it takes like a second to process the
fact that you went to that
place i would imagine it would be like
if you go to jail and you weren't
expecting that to happen too
it's like the same type of feeling
because you're like being held somewhere
against your will
and like you have no control over it um
but yeah it took me like a while to get
to a place of like
comfort with it i mean i talked about it
on my podcast after it happened just
because i felt like i had to because it
feels like
you know like mental health stuff is so
it it affects so many different people
and especially
in so many ways so many ways and
especially especially now with the
pandemic and stuff it's like
you know it's sometimes it's okay to
need help and it's okay to not be okay
and like that doesn't make you any less
strong or
you know or human no so
overall it was a good thing because i
don't think i would have ever been able
to get off of adderall because it is so
addicting
you think you'd still be on it yeah you
do yeah
yeah cause like it's impossible to do
anything when you're getting off of it
if that makes sense yeah without a
psychiatrist
obviously you like marijuana so that's
interesting because that's
more of a relaxing thing than an upper
but
weed makes me focus like that though
yeah well
not like that though not like that
i'm like let's do this for now and get
all that done eyelashes yeah now i just
smoke weed
yeah i'm like weed the occasional
mushroom chip
that's it and some water yeah what else
do you [ __ ] need nothing
that is it i'm yeah so do your
parents or anyone in your life that
knows you went there did
any of them ever look at you with that
little or doubt you
or think anything like has it been a
little like oh she's going crazy again
have you had that
no not since no i mean like i think my
parents are like after it happened they
were like
hyper focused on me for a second which
was
weird i was like because they started
taking advice
as a woman in your 30s to be monitored
by your parents
yeah i totally i could totally
understand weird yeah
um but to their credit they were like
really there for me
they were more supportive of this than
you actually wanting to do
uh child acting yeah way more supportive
yeah that's what parents do yeah they
helped me yeah
uh they helped me pay off my ambulance
bill
which the whole trip is not was not
cheap
i would have preferred a vacation yeah i
bet send me to the bahamas to get clean
yeah you know what i mean yeah for real
leave me here on a beach
yeah same price seriously here on a
beach for a month
yeah so you what was it like being off
adderall
i mean was it um i just feel like i have
like my life back like
i just feel like i'm i'm more happy yeah
when i was on it
because like you've been off now for
what a year and a half a year and a half
and you you're happy off of it yeah yeah
good i'm like happy
and i'm just more creative and just like
more my authentic self
because i'm not just like oh gotta go do
this gotta go do this gotta go do this
you know what i mean like i'm not
waking your roommate up at 8 00 am yeah
wake up [ __ ]
you want breakfast yeah what are you
doing in my room i don't know
calling people who i shouldn't be
calling at like 7 a.m
crazy like what's going on like several
times like
stuff like that did you have to send
like as part of therapy and stuff that
they ask you to send apologies to
anybody or anything like that no they
didn't make me do that
i've gotten those over the years oh like
for like four years later
oh you're in you're in therapy yeah yeah
yeah yeah every time like ah now he's
right back
hey no worries yeah yeah we were all
good take care yeah
another another anonymous series 12
stepper yeah
i get them all i've had food addiction
email me i've had
sex addiction email me i've had
[ __ ] uh cocaine addiction email me
all years later all
i'm like hey i just want to let you know
i was an [ __ ] i'm like it's all good
yeah all good yeah yeah so no i didn't
really have
i mean like i did apologize to like the
people who i
uh put out
but um i didn't do like any formal like
a men's
no yeah well i mean that's nothing to be
embarrassed about i get it
i get it well when you have your 101
dalmatian shoes on and they don't have
any uh
shoelaces in them in your 30s and you're
in your 30s there's your own woman
you're a ground woman what are you doing
you're begging for a cough drop
please can i get a haul i don't have a
problem with that yes
can i get a chloroseptic like spray like
no
um
so since then do you get like
do you meditate dude what do you do to
help focus like what
every day okay what do you do for extra
four miles a day minimum
running hiking walking or hiking wow no
matter what you just get out and move
yes okay i haven't done it today but i
do it every day
um that's the main thing and like i have
to be like out in nature
and do you find like when you walk for
me i'm asking because when i walk and i
listen to music i'm
never more clear like and open you know
what i mean
especially out in the sun it feels so
good we're lucky to be in southern
california so like i turn my phone i
off or i put on airplane mode and then i
just play music
and then so no one can bother me and
then i just do my walk
and then after that i'm like able to
focus i mean the thing is
i can focus on comedy podcast
writing stuff that i'm excited about yes
and like that's what i have not math
they're not like
data entry not like an excel sheet and
like i think that that's
where there needs to be changes and like
the way that
kids learn and like there isn't just a
one-size-fits-all type of education and
not everyone's has the same strengths so
i think it's like
like i know if i have kids i want to
encourage them to like explore different
learning styles and just stuff like that
because i think i'd
it's like if you don't fit into like
this box of like
what it means to be like a good student
or
then there's like weird pressure you
know what i mean yeah and we were
talking before this about just college
in general it's a [ __ ] money trap for
so many people
and you know you really a lot of times
how many directors and everything else
we know coming out of usc and you guys
are [ __ ] working in
starbucks myself personally did you go
to usc no i went to chapman but oh yeah
you said chat man
is hell is it it really was it was like
did you feel like unaccepted or just
overlooked or what
break it down i felt bored i was like
this is the most sterile
it will seem perfect from the outside
because it was like a
private school that's expensive to go to
it was like a lot of like rich kids
everywhere
like rich kids like blonde rich kids
like i felt like i was diverse because i
had dark hair
i was like does anybody like me because
i have dark hair
like everyone was [ __ ] blonde with
blue eyes and i felt like i woke up in
like this weird dystopian hell
and i didn't want to be in a sorority
because i went to all girls catholic
high school so i was like
oh man yeah i'm done with [ __ ] yeah
you know what i mean
like that's that's what's weird is
because like i spent so much time around
women
in high school that it's been
interesting to now spend so much time
around men because of stand up it's been
such like a different
boy what a group to be spending time
around these days
yeah i know but i love comics i miss all
my comic
friends too from being like in the house
yeah yeah we're all stuck in the house
yeah so like adderall if i can compare
it to anything it's like
the mountain dew of
prescribed pills okay because mountain
dew is like kind of cracky
that jack yeah yeah yeah
cracky yeah all right
um so i want to ask you some more stuff
though yeah
um with
well i mean with comedy right now being
where it is what are you doing to stay
focused with that do you ever want to go
have you ever thought about going back
do you ever feel like you need that [ __ ]
again like how are you keeping that
adderall yeah no i know never you're
done no
you like i don't even want to be around
anyone who's on it
because i know that place that they're
at and it's
not a good place even though it feels
good at that time
wow like it's weird because i think that
if we're having to give people
prescribed
speed to function in society then there
is something wrong with society
amen you know what i'm saying like that
that no yeah especially kids especially
yeah you're right children is uh because
there's so many of them on then you got
80d
80 hd i don't even know what the hell
the real
signs are yeah put them in sports put
them in like a
play put them in something else like the
energy out somewhere else
yeah totally and like i think that
um like encourage different like
extracurricular activities especially
too i think
so how are you staying focused right now
exercise is a big part of it coffee
i have my coffee i have my coffee i
exercise i have like no problem focusing
on podcasting
writing um making video content like
that's what you love i love doing it so
it's like all fun
and playful for me it's the and even
like
and it was like once i quit my personal
assistant job i just wanted to get off
of it and i was already taking the steps
to get off of it but i don't think i
would have been able to do it
fully myself without that hole yeah
isn't that crazy
yeah i mean no i didn't mean it like
that no sorry
i really don't know i'm not easily
offended about the word crazy don't
worry
all right but all right isn't that
something
it's insane you would have to [ __ ] go
through something
like that like it's you know we talk
about it all the time like there's
no way to to even try to convince
somebody in the middle of that [ __ ] that
you'll see
you'll see this will be the it's going
to be the best thing that ever happens
that you did three days at a [ __ ]
yeah 100
because even though dara yeah it was
more popular
yeah i mean number two is not bad you
were only there for three i thought i
was
killing the game that girl i was like
tacklers everywhere the psych ward is
heckling me now
oh this comedy store princess
this girl
one of my roommates from the psych ward
called me post psych ward
to check and see if i was doing okay and
i was like
in my own which was nice but in my head
i was thinking
it's not a good sign when the your
roommate from the cycle are just
following up with you
to make sure you're okay i was like are
you okay [ __ ]
why are you finding me do you know what
other people were in there for
do you remember there's like because it
always blows me away when you like
people go to prison and it's like
i just stole a car and they're like yeah
well you're in there with a guy that
killed seven people
one girl who was in there for a long
time she had been in there for two or
three weeks
and she was like i don't know what was
going on with her because like
everyone seems if you like go with the
flow
and you have good behavior they let you
out
so it's like i don't know what she was
doing before i got there to be in there
for two weeks but she must have been
acting a full before i got him
but then when i came i was like the one
that was a little wild
so i don't really really yeah but i
don't remember it because they
tranquilized me to get me in there i
guess they
i was like kicking and screaming a lot
don't you wish you could there was a
video yeah
go back and watch yourself when you
weren't yourself be like i did that
yes because i was out of control i can't
imagine you being
[ __ ] insane it was insane
i was making dick jokes in the ambulance
energy johnson energy and then i started
laughing and like high five
that's good like i'm like i'm crushing
right now yes
amazing that's crazy
crazy outfits they probably tell
everyone that [ __ ] story like this
one time this little white chick got in
here
[ __ ] said ernie over there hey man
big johnson
and you [ __ ] loved it
there's no one you've seen so much [ __ ]
if that doesn't make you laugh i'm
making my face hurt that is so good
i can't believe yeah i was writing out
princess shank and passing it around
that's my handle follow me are you guys
on social media
follow me it's like why are you not
working at the psych ward
go home that is so
i mean i'm sorry to laugh no yeah i know
where that's what we do here but you
know
god damn it is funny it really i don't
know if i can get that chicken feta i
wonder if they do
delivery right now they probably would
love to do it
okay can we get that chicken ahead you
know what i'm saying this little bit old
time
i'll promote it
i'll put on my instagram story if you
could hook me up with a
counterfeit mcrib i want to try it now
it's [ __ ] incredible i really do want
i don't know if i want to do what it
takes to get there to try it but i
definitely want to i can give you the
cocktail
i um take a bunch of adderall and then
just stop and see what happens
[ __ ] i mean i i dated a girl
very briefly one time that was on some
kind of um
d med yeah or like uh and wasn't
probably probably jesus christ properly
weaning off of it either and she would
do like this i'm like what's going on
she's like i'm getting these like
electrical charges that are maybe it was
like alexa pro or something like that
and i'm like
oh i have heard that about and she would
totally i'm like yeah
i was like this isn't going to work
it's a wrap i'm like what's happening
it's like these electric impulses i'm
like why don't you talk to your doctor
how to get off of that [ __ ] probably
because you're [ __ ] weirded me out
and i was a rap one that was a couple
dates and i was like
yeah no i'm not gonna watch you twitch
from elections yeah
you won't get off your [ __ ] right yeah
no
it's like because like i didn't know
realize that it's like a
controlled substance that you actually
have to like wean off of in like a
proper
way and like probably the best way to
get off of it is to go to like
a rehab not to just like do it cold
turkey because you feel really sick when
you're getting off of it too you're like
oh
yeah sweating and [ __ ] yeah it sounds
like that sounds like heroin
like no it is getting off of it it was
honestly
so bad that it's it's so bad that you
would never want to be on it again
that's how i felt i hear you yeah have
you ever had a reaction like that to any
medic are you allergic to anything
or no not really had you ever blacked
out or anything before
drinking yeah from drinking yeah but not
from like
an actual like psychosis but it was a
combination of like lack of sleep
mixed with um the
[ __ ] not taking the medications
it was like so much trauma in such a
small amount of time yeah but basically
it saved my life isn't it so which is
crazy
there's that yeah yeah because i don't
know if i would have
because i i knew i knew for a long time
i wanted to get off of it
but i don't know if i would have been
able to at least like not in the society
we were living in
pre-pandemic because everything was so
like
you have i felt like i'm a perfectionist
too
so for me adderall was the perfect storm
because it's like
look at how clean everything is look at
how organized everything is because
i am i can be organized but it doesn't
come like really naturally
to me like i have to like try to be
organized but on adderall i was like
everything's [ __ ] organized this
never looked better [ __ ]
[Laughter]
well um i really appreciate you coming
on yeah
and sharing all this yeah this is i've
yeah that's an amazing story i had no i
i'm glad
thank you because i don't i hear kids
and like already in my daughter's
classes are on this stuff and and you
know i always get worried about any time
you're putting kids on any kind of
medication
yeah like if you're a parent and you're
thinking about it or if you have a kid
that's owned it like
really like second take another look at
that because
it's like all right so let me ask you
then since
first time here advice for your um 16
year old self
stop going to the tanning salon
you used to do that a lot oh my god full
addiction to that
really and encino
how many times a day once a day okay
but every day mm-hmm every day every day
for how long
year at least one to two years
and did you get any kind of melanoma
with cancer no but i got
i looked so dark because my mom is
puerto rican so i can get dark so i was
like a different ethnicity
if you look at my college id i don't
have it i wish i did but i
look like you can just see my teeth and
like the whites of my eyes
the rest of me is like so tan i look
like a fully
like ethnically ambiguous you'd be like
what
i remember i went to like i was obsessed
with tanning i got like a spray tan for
prom
and my date was indian and i was darker
than him come on
and i was like maybe i shouldn't have
done the level three spray
like like there's different levels of
tan yeah
i did level three and i look it's like
orange like dark burnt orange
dye spray what happened when you showed
up was he like what the [ __ ]
for his parents like you got a nice
indian girl
i don't even never remember i just like
it i was like i was obsessed with
tanning i was like i'm really glad i got
off tanning in adderall because that
could have been
just like like a leather face yeah
you're broken
like adderall [ __ ] with like neon pink
nails
like for a while i was doing neon pink
nails with the tanning
i was like this is a great look this is
a hot look
people don't get it these nails are on
point right here blue
yeah this is who i am now much better
yeah um well thank you so much thank you
for coming on
sharing all that yeah will you please
again promote whatever you'd like yes
okay so follow me at princess shank
princess like normal and then another
s-h-e-n-k
check out my podcast shank s-h-e-n-k
uh wherever there's podcasts all
streaming platforms that's what i was
looking for spotify itunes blah blah
blah
youtube sarah weinchank check out shanks
for smoking on comedy central digital
and uh that's it awesome thank you so
much
thank you i really appreciate you coming
it was it was a good time yeah a great
episode
uh as always ryan sickler on all social
media
ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you all
next week
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]